[Music]
in less than one hour all 27 EU leaders
meet in this room everything needs to be
ready so Christine what are you doing
I'm going through the seating plan and
making sure that the name plates are
actually where they are supposed to be
this is where the president of the
European Council who chairs the meeting
will be seated so what else needs to be
checked a lot we need to go through one
final check of the meeting room but also
check the interpretation channels and
the microphone t t interesting what
about these earpieces Ah that's for the
leaders to listen and speak in their
language interpretation boots are right
behind so all set yes now we just wait
for the EU leaders to arrive great